[Musique]
bonjour jusqu'à présent nous ont motivés
le temps vous êtes le secrétaire
académique du snetaa fo martinique on va
parler d'éducation nationale de cette
rentrée 2010 est mais on va quand même
vous demander pour commencer je sais
prison votre réaction à ces images
plutôt impressionnante de la rivière de
caisse d'un vert hier après-midi hhr la
proximité de deux écoles élémentaires
question toute simple avez vous
l'impression aujourd'hui jusqu'à présent
que la sécurité auprès de nos
établissements est assurée est-ce que
c'est suffisant face à de tels
événements mais je dirais que pas
vraiment puisque la preuve et il faut
savoir que la sécurité c'est quand même
quelque chose que sous laquelle il faut
être réactif à tout moment donc il
suffit pas de dire bon ballon file en
corner d'une période où tout le monde le
sait où à n'importe quel moment
notamment pour un cyclone après
l'ouragan
on peut avoir démonté les eaux donc je
crois que bon mais les habitants sont
avertis mais aussi il faut que au niveau
des écoles au niveau des responsabilités
ceux qui ont des responsabilités des
enfants qui sont dans une école que les
mesures de surveillance soit un plus
stricte
cette rentrée 2010 et on a l'impression
très bêtement qu'il ya une sorte de
grogne grandissante une grande syndicale
qui s'organise qui risque d'exploser
quel contraste par rapport à l'an
dernier ce sont les contrats aidés qui
ont mis le feu aux poudres
oui les contrats et aider effectivement
c'est donc on va dire que c'est
peut-être la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase mais je crois qu'il ya
pas mal de problèmes en amont on va les
voir et je pouvais me des contrats aidés
je trouve que bombay
le gouvernement attendait quand même à
réagir parce que nous avons l'exemple de
la réunion qui nous annonçait déjà qu'il
fallait faire attention nous avons eu
quand même
c'est qui ce sont leurs réactions
mais avant toute chose ces contrats
aidés dans le secteur de l'enseignement
combien sont-ils que font-ils et
pourquoi crystallis t-il autant
bon alors comme chief il faut savoir que
nous n'avons pas tous les chiffres mais
quand même ou l'un des chiffres
significatifs que nous nous connaissions
dès le mois de juin parce que nous avons
voté contre justement ces propositions
où nous avions 920 et contrat unique
d'insertion cfi sommes passés à 380 soir
d'une perte depuis 60 % bon et au niveau
des établissements bombes ainsi des
diminutions par dizaines sous lens on
est sur l'ensemble des deux là de
l'académie martinique
bon le jeu facile on a favorisé alors si
ces contrats aidés c'est important ces
contrats il est bon ben ils vont
assurer la sécurité l'accueil
l'accueillir au niveau des
établissements le matin donc forcément
la sécurité l'encadrement
ensuite au niveau de la vie scolaire
bambin il faut renforcer le personnel
des scolaires ils vont aussi au niveau
de l'internât bon quand l'internât il
manque du personnel donc ils vont
renforcer aussi spécieux personnel au
niveau de la restauration
là aussi ce sont des personnes notamment
des contrats types c'est m
vous comprenez pourquoi j'ai commencé
par la rivière case navire hier à
schoelcher de ces contrats et à ses
contraintes et peuvent par exemple aider
à la sécurité de l'état fait alors
qu'ils accusent et vous l'état le
président emmanuel macron son premier
ministre edouard philippe ils ont
pourtant dit que dans nos pays un autre
mais rien ne devrait changer concernant
ces contrats aidés oui mais dès les
gouvernements et se suivent et c'est
toujours la même chose moment on allait
les gouvernements qui s'expriment qu'ils
font des promesses et on ne voit rien
venir a clairement l'état a menti l'état
ne tient pas ses engagements
et donc voilà les conséquences pense que
bon moi je crois que l'action doit doit
se faire tout de suite après alors que
faire puisque vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure jusqu'à présent la réunion s'est
mobilisée est-ce qu ici en martinique il
y a de quoi être déçu par la
mobilisation de nos élus ce sont eux qui
peuvent faire bouger les lignes ce sont
les politiques nos parlementaires comme
d'habitude dans une très grande majorité
ne s'exprime pas et puis les maires se
sont réunis une de froid et puis c'est
tout oui je crois qu'on peut se poser
des questions mais je crois que on peut
en guérir tous leurs titres homair ce
faire nous nous lançons un appel
pas seulement au maire un appel à tous
les responsables et puis aussi à ceux
aux acteurs du théorêt
tous les garçons qui se mobilisent ben
oui parce que nous avons une situation
quand même qu ils suffisamment
importante suffisamment la population
doit se mobiliser pour faire pression
sur les élus qui devraient faire
position pression sur le gouvernement
mais attendez ceux qui sont sous le
titre de cette question c'est
malheureusement le cas tu as lu que
c'est celui qui est sur le terrain qui
se trouve en difficulté qui doit mais
effectivement lancé des cris ou ou s'est
mobilisée de vous trouver des élus de
martinique trop frileux sur cette
question je trouve que il n'y a pas il y
as certainement je pense dans le cadre
dans lequel on aujourd'hui c'est souvent
le cas pour différentes situations
il y avait un problème qui fait que bon
bah ils sont pas écoutés ils sont pas
entendus donc là dessus peut-être ne
s'exprime pas suffisamment il ne
s'exprime pas peut-être suffisamment
lors de cette ligue mais ce matin
davantage jusqu'à présent davantage
davantage et puis bon mais de continuer
aussi à nous soutenir à soutenir ceux
qui sont concernés par ces problèmes de
manière à ce que nous obtenons des
solutions a dit ce faisant la question
des néo-titulaires dos à présent
pourquoi ne pas admettre une fois pour
toute et arrêter définitivement ces
agitations tour de personnes qui veulent
rester chez elle et pourtant qui
s'inscrivent dans un concours où la
règle est quand même de partir si le
ministère le décide
autant ne pas y aller non où il voulait
mais pas aussi 5
mais il est hors de question
nous sommes de ceux qui disent que
effectivement c'est un concours national
mais quand on prend les dossiers au cas
par cas quand on constate que très
souvent nous avons des collègues qui
sont des ex contractuels qui ont exercé
pendant un certain temps qu'ils ont des
seins certainement et qu'ils ont des
engagements familiaux des
responsabilités et à qui on demande de
passer le concours se stabiliser on sait
qu'il ya des moyens qui leur permettront
de pouvoir rester et que par la suite on
constate que au niveau du ministère pour
nous demander de prendre par la
solidarité nationale
on affecte systématiquement les
collègues dans d'autres académies alors
que l'on constate à l'entrée que nos
enfants
le ces élèves sont sans enseignant s'est
assise à table c'est valable pour celui
qui passe le concours dans le sud de la
france à l'est de la france à l'ouest de
lahore eux aussi bouge
non c'est pas le même contexte parce que
il bouge il bouillante mais il ne laisse
pas ils ne laissent pas quand même de
dvd enfance ans enseignante dans des
disciplines où les rectorats et région
martinique
assil aussi le cas en martinique c'est
malheureusement le cas depuis quelques
années nous le disons dans certaines
disciplines où nous avons des preuves
encore là nous avons examiné je suis je
peux parti de dire un certain nombre de
disciplines comment comme en maths
sciences comme en économie gestion comme
par exemple en mécanique génie mécanique
et bonfim leti square où nous avons des
la recherche de contractuels pouvoirs
nouveaux contractuels et la rectrice
d'académie a affirmé sur nos antennes en
début de semaine sur nos antennes télé
qu'elle avait obtenu que 16 de ses notes
au type de titulaires restent en place
en martinique c'est un chiffre qui vous
fait réagir commencé assez c'est
suffisant elle aurait pu faire mieux et
du sérieux ce n'est pas ce qu'elle est
ce qu'elle devait chercher à faire mieux
je pense que oui parce que bon ben il
n'a pas dit que ce sont des chiffres
qu'elle nous a communiqué n'a pas dit
qui avait 39 demande de révision
d'affectation 1,32 mondory vise une
affectation
c'est déjà un chiffre qui déjà en
dessous parce que en réalité il ya des
personnes qui font des demandes de vivre
une affectation qui ne parviennent pas
directement aux étoiles montini donc 16
89 et je pense que c'est pas suffisant
d'autant plus que les dossiers c'est là
que nous intervenons les dossiers de
plusieurs personnes qui n'ont pas eu de
réponses positives
ce sont des cas difficiles des
situations mère de famille père de
famille personne ayant tutelle la
tutelle d'ascendant donc et personne à
55 ans cathy dépensés à chaque début de
saison justement très scolaire qu'est-ce
qu'il faut il faut réécrire légalement
les règles il faudrait que ce soit les
les politiques qui vont au créneau pour
une autre stature régionale à ces
concours d'entrée à l'éducation
nationale je pense qu'il faut il faut
porter une attention et une attention
plus grands aussi combien savent combien
d'années vous dites ça les syndicats
vous n'avez pas à vous faire entendre
on le dit va autant d'oeuvres autant de
fois qu'il le faut sinon on peut vous
enregistrer aujourd'hui puis ressortir
la banque tout ça n'aurait dans toujours
pas du tout parce que justement j'allais
vous obliger à les continuer en vous
disant il ya eu des actions très fortes
qui ont été menées par le passé
moi je crois que si ça continue des
façons mais on sera obligé de mener des
actions fortes pour nous faire entendre
sur ce sujet il est malheureux de voir
que mon père justement de l'énergie
alors que bombay syndicalement on aurait
dû pouvoir y porter notre énergie vers
une amélioration du système éducatif de
la pédagogie par exemple jusqu'à présent
les tzr vous les connaissez ce sont les
titulaires de
zone de l'emplacement zone de
remplacement pourquoi les syndicats ne
font pas entendre leur voix sur cette
question plutôt épineuse ce sont des
personnels qui ne travaillent plus parce
que leur discipline a disparu tout
simplement des écrans radars ce sont des
personnels qui restent à la maison qui
sont payés qui ne travaillent pas
certains acceptent parfois la
reconversion d'autres non est-ce que là
quelque part il n'y a pas comme un
parfum de scandale à savoir qu'il ya des
gens dans l'éducation nationale en que
vous plaignez qu'il n'y a pas
suffisamment d'enseignants des personnes
payés à ne rien faire oui mais c'est
c'est un argument que sort
l'administration systématiquement c'est
alors que c'est pas la distraction c'est
moi ce matin oui mais là vous le vous
leur lit et cet engouement certain
engouement 7è session et qui sont huit
déchetteries arqués ses personnels il
n'ya pas il n'est pas totalement
vérifier parce que parce que je vous
assure que l'administration fait ce
qu'il faut pour repérer ces personnes et
il est ramené dans le système est ce
qu'il faut dit aussi il y a les
personnes qui ont des pathologies qui
qui ne peuvent pas être devant les
élèves
il y à la reconversion la reconversion
est mis en place
alors il ya peut-être aussi la cause qui
a ramené justement ce que je suis au
plus d'allant dans l'académie on ne dit
pas à une certaine époque pour certains
lecteurs
on avait fait rentrer en masse un
certain nombre de personnes qu'on
n'avait pas forcément besoin et ça ça
vient pas de nous ça on ne le dit pas
donc aujourd'hui on n'est pas
responsable de s'être
une injection cette gestion qui a été
fait de manière hasardeuse à un certain
moment donc on ne peut pas payer les
conséquences le déficit nous ne sommes
pas vraiment responsable ce déficit
merci je serai présent on rappelle de
cette série très limitée
[Musique]